Ross what is the first step or first
series of steps in creating a web series
well the first thing you have to work on
is the basic concept what is the basic
story you're gonna tell on an ongoing
basis and you know hopefully it's not
the nine trillion slacker series on
among web series there that it has some
uniqueness to it there something that's
different you should probably make sure
you're writing about something that
you're familiar with yourself so that
you can really be authentic in the
details and the language and then once
you identify the topic and the central
dramatic problem of the series or what
you're going to explore you've got to
populate it with characters and I often
find with my students that the biggest
mistake they make with the character
development is they think of characters
as like a laundry list okay there it's a
dormitory so there's a guy who's a jock
and there's a woman who's a cheerleader
and then there's the guy who's the nerd
and they're just as if these characters
are floating independent of each other
and that's not really how it works when
you're developing a series a series has
an architecture to how the characters
all work together so I try to tell the
students I work with to think of it more
rather than a vertical list as a wheel
with your central character in the
middle and then spokes coming out for
all the other characters how do they put
new pressures on your character how do
they put pressures or conflicts on each
other as well so that because that's
where you're gonna get the stories from
that's where the legs of the series so
to speak will emanate from is these
conflicts and so you need to develop
that architecture what would you advise
as the length of each episode you know
it vary so greatly there I mean some
people say you should never have
anything longer than this many minutes
and yet house of cards was it's not a
web series but it was released over the
internet and had nearly one hour
episodes there so the my sort of stock
answer for that is when you look on the
Internet at video and you see the menu
that has the length of each episode
what's the length beyond which you won't
click yourself if
if you won't click if it's more than six
minutes then you probably shouldn't
write a web series that has episodes
longer than six minutes because your
Sensibility seems to not want to go
longer than that there but I think it's
entirely possible I just looked at one
of Freddie Wong's web series the video
High School thing they have 30 minute
episodes there so it's you know it's
really flexible but I think you should
gauge by your personal preferences so
going back to that Allah added sort of
write what you know and write what you
would like and not what you think you're
supposed a D&C once right yeah I mean
you know guessing what the audience
wants is you know if people could
accurately do that they would but you
can't do that with writing songs you
can't do that with creating feature
films or standard television shows on
broadcaster cable networks they it's a
trial and error process and I think
you're always best writing what gets you
excited what you find compelling
yourself what you think is funny or what
you think is dramatic or interesting and
then hopefully there'll be enough
like-minded people if you do it well
that'll be your audience so how soon
should one factor in conflict let's take
a 30 minute webisode when when is there
a specific marker or there's no real
science to it when well I you know in
general writing theory I think every
scene should have conflict if there
isn't conflict in a scene I'm not sure
what's driving it dramatically there you
know there are exceptions to this I mean
you you may just want to establish the
atmosphere or who the character is in
general but as a rule of thumb and one
of my writing mentors made us when we
were writing our outlines say what the
conflict was in every scene and you know
it doesn't have to be maybe it's a
person cliche scene waking up in the
morning but it's more interesting if
they're waking up the morning and
they're late for work then if they're
just waking up in the morning and
drinking coffee
you